hey guys today we're gonna explain the
full childhood of Shigure Aki the
crusties villain in my hero academia and
the successor to all four one and if you
only watch the anime and would rather
wait like 1 or 2 years to find out this
information then please exit this video
but check out some of my other spoiler
free content oh and also don't forget to
subscribe so suga Rocky is the grandson
of Nana shamora who was a powerful hero
and master to a certain symbol of peace
his actual legal name is tang called
Shimura and as a child he lived with his
parents his sister and his grandparents
though obviously his grandparents on the
other side of his family now this
household was somewhat dysfunctional
given that she Iraqis father had an
intense hatred fierros this hatred was
born out of the fact that his mother
nana shamora had died whilst fighting
all-4-one when he was just a young boy
but despite his father's ideology young
Tenko had a fascination with heroes and
held dreams of becoming one in fact he
even went as far as to say that his
father's rules regarding heroes denied
him everything that he was those are the
words of someone who really really wants
to be a hero
this fascination led to shigaraki being
frequently beaten locked outside the
house and generally just being made to
feel worthless also despite being of the
age Tenko never appeared to manifest any
quirk at least until he was brought home
one day by this guy in a suit hmm after
this Tenko sister discovered a picture
revealing that their grandmother was a
hero something which made sugar aki
incredibly happy but when their father
discovered that someone had tampered
with the picture shigaraki sister
essentially just framed him I mean I
guess that's what siblings do all the
time
you don't want to get in trouble so you
kind of just say your sibling did it but
in this case that was definitely the
wrong move to make as the subsequent
beating that tanka received was so
severe that it really kind of got the
ball rolling regarding his quirk
activating so whilst he was recovering
from this beating from his dad he
innocently hugged his pet dog and then
out of nowhere the dog's body just like
decays into a bloody mess all over the
floor so naturally this would be quite
confusing for a young child to witness
then just as Tenko is kind of coming to
grips with what just happened
his sister comes outside to apologize
for framing him only to see the dead dog
on the floor and in his confusion tanco
grabs on to his sister only for her to
burst into a million pieces he then puts
his hands on the ground instead but this
makes it even worse
as the ground itself begins to quake
killing off anyone who dares to step
outside this happened repeatedly over
and over again to his mother his
grandparents and so only one member of
his family remained his dad now when his
father finally stepped outside to see
what all the commotion was about he
realized that he had messed up
despite tankers dad trying to apologize
he intentionally jumped towards his dad
and grabbed him in the face
killing him instantly so this was the
first manifestation of Shigure Rocky's
decay quirk and unlike what we've seen
in the anime it was actually activated
on things that he wasn't directly
touching because for the vast majority
of his family he didn't actually make
contact with them but rather he made
contact with the ground and then because
they happened to step outside onto the
ground they themselves were decayed so
this is like his normal quote but we
know just on steroids so after this
incident
tenko was orphaned and homeless being
left to fend for himself on the streets
of Japan not once did anyone stop to
help him except for this old lady but
she kind of got creeped out by his
crusty eyes no one stopped to help him
because they assumed that a hero would
naturally deal with the situation this
led to him being ignored completely
until all-4-one showed up well for one
used this incident the fact that no one
came to help him to stimulate Teng COEs
newfound hatred for Hiro society Tenko
was then given the disembodied hands of
his family members to manipulate him
into never forgetting the negative
emotions he felt at that moment when he
killed them all for one then gave him a
home with the intention that he would
one day take over the league of villains
and become the symbol of fear renaming
the boy from tanker Shimura to tomorrow
Shigure Aki now the name tamra in this
context essentially means to signify the
sadness that comes with a death and the
last name shigaraki this is actually
quite interesting it is the last name of
wolf one himself so we finally have some
personal details about all-4-one also I
forgot to mention when suga Rock he was
fending for himself on the streets there
were these two guys who are basically
being complete dicks to him and once all
for one found him he basically convinced
Shigure Aki to let go and just go back
and kill them which is what I call
excellent parenting remember he's still
a young kid he's like five or six if if
I remember correctly and there you have
it
that was shigga Rocky's entire childhood
that we know so far
explained and actually within the next
few weeks most likely next week I'm
going
be putting out a my villain academia
explaining video where I'm gonna be
going through the entire arc all the
chapters from beginning to end in less
than 10 minutes so think of it as a
chapter review just on a massive scale
and just before you go please don't
forget to subscribe I have new videos
every week
thank you guys peace